efe es una función finita cuyo dominio
está compuesto por las letras desde la a
hasta la en la siguiente tabla esta de
aquí nos da los valores de salida para
cada entrada en el dominio de f así es
que por ejemplo si x es igual a a osea
si la entrada es a entonces la salida es
menos 6 ok
fd a es menos 6 si le damos a la función
f la entrada b nos regresa menos 3 si le
damos la entrada se nos da menos 6 si le
damos de nos da menos 2 y si le damos la
entrada y nos regresa la salida menos 6
ahora construye el diagrama de mapeo de
efe arrastrando los puntos extremos de
los segmentos de la gráfica de abajo de
tal forma que el mapeo le asigne el
elemento del rango correcto a cada uno
de los elementos del dominio y luego
determina si la función
efe es invertible así es que tenemos
aquí al diagrama este óvalo morado
representa el domi
de la función efe y este óvalo verde
representa el rango así es que lo que la
función efe hace es que si le das una
entrada en el dominio de f una entrada
de estas la función f mapea a esa
entrada a algún elemento del rango así
es que por ejemplo si le damos la
entrada a efe nos lleva a menos 6
entonces por aquí
nos tiene que llevar a menos 6 luego la
función efe nos manda la b a menos 3 así
es que por aquí la b nos tiene que
mandar a menos 3 luego la se nos manda a
menos 6 la c nos manda a menos 6 y aquí
es muy importante notar que tenemos dos
elementos del dominio que nos mandan a
menos 6 por el momento no tenemos ningún
problema con eso porque no evita que efe
sea una función sin embargo cuando
estemos viendo si es invertible o no
esto de aquí si hace que sea un poco
difícil que efe sea invertible pero
bueno la entrada
se va a menos 2 d se va a menos 2 si a
la función f le damos la entrada de nos
da la salida menos 2 y finalmente si a
efe le damos la entrada y nos manda a
menos 6 otra vez ok y nos lo manda al
menos 6 bueno tenemos aquí una
visualización de cómo funciona la
función
efe de como manda a los elementos del
dominio desde a hasta que a los
elementos del rango pero ahora nos
tenemos que preguntar si f es una
función invertible y ya te digo una
pequeña pista al respecto ahora para que
la función f sea invertible tiene que
haber una función que vaya del rango al
dominio que tenga el mapeo inverso pero
esa otra función si tiene que cumplir
con todas las características de ser
función y a esta otra función inversa si
le damos la entrada menos 2 nos tiene
que dar la salida de y también si le
damos
entrada menos 3 a esta función inversa
nos tiene que dar la salida de si le
damos el valor de entrada menos 6 a esta
función inversa hipotética qué valor de
salida nos tendría que dar por crear y
porque no podemos tener ninguna función
a la que si le damos una entrada nos de
tres posibles valores de salida
distintos a pse-ee porque hay porque las
funciones si les das una entrada de
mapea únicamente a un valor entonces a
final de cuentas no podemos encontrar
una función inversa que tenga el
diagrama de mapeo inverso
ok porque la función inversa tendría que
mapear al menos 6 a estos tres valores
distintos pero entonces ya no sería una
función así es que la función f
no es invertible pero bueno hagamos otro
ejercicio ahora tenemos que hacer
exactamente lo mismo pero con estos
números tenemos aquí los elementos del
dominio y aquí los elementos del rango y
lo que queremos hacer es
el diagrama de mapeo de f se va a menos
36 la a se va a menos 36 la b es mapeada
a 9 la b se va al 9 c se va a menos 4
csb menos 4 la función mapea a de a 49
y finalmente efe manda a la entrada a
25s va a 25 ahora la pregunta es si esta
función es invertible bueno pues
pensemos al respecto pensemos en que
tendría que hacer la función inversa
hipotética para empezar tendría que
tomar a cada uno de los elementos del
rango y mandarlos en el mapeo inverso
así es que si le diéramos la entrada 49
a nuestra función inversa hipotética nos
tendría que mandar a d y si le diéramos
la entrada 25 nos mandaría a e si le
damos un 9 nos da un b si le damos un -4
nos debe de dar un c y si le damos la
entrada menos 36 nos da la salida y así
es que como estamos viendo fácilmente se
puede construir una función inversa así
es que la función f
definitivamente es invertible y ahora
otra forma en la que podemos pensar en
esto es que este es un mapeo
uno a uno cada uno de los elementos del
dominio corresponde a un elemento del
rango distinto y cada elemento del rango
corresponde a un solo elemento del
dominio aquí no tenemos que dos
elementos del dominio sean asignados a
un mismo elemento del rango y eso hace
que si se ha invertido en fin espero que
te parezca interesante